[Music]
during this book that I wrote called
pilgrimage my search for the real pope
francis i talked to not just Catholics
because pope francis has a slew of
different friends in argentina in
roaming around the world of all
different faiths i talked to a couple of
Rabbis in bonus eras father who had lost
his daughter in the bombing of the
Jewish Community Center I've talked to
atheists and to Christians of other
denominations and what he really does
what Pope Francis does i think
beautifully is challenges all you can be
an atheist or you cannot believe in
organized religion and just try to
develop your own relationship with God
you can be in more formal relationship
with god through the catholic church or
Protestantism it doesn't matter what
he's really trying to do is to challenge
us from a place of joy it's not filled
with Catholic or Jewish guilt it's from
a place of joy to want to develop a
better relationship with God and to
develop a better relationship with you
your fellow human beings he tells this
great story about giving food to a woman
who had to prostitute herself at times
to feed her three young kids a husband
had left her and she came around
Christmas time to talk to at that point
father bergoglio Pope Francis and she
said thank you for the food and he said
I'm glad you got it and she said but
what I really want to thank you for is
you always called me signora and when
you think about that you know he treated
her with dignity and respect and too
often in America you know just speaking
on my own behalf you know when you see a
homeless person you try to avoid them I
don't give him the money all the time I
don't make eye contact with him I surely
don't ask him his name or call him Sir
or mrs. and what he's teaching us
through that gesture is that you have to
treat each other with respect and with
dignity you have to enter into the chaos
and the confusion but also the joys of
other people's lives and that takes
getting out of your comfort zone right
and you don't have to be a Catholic or a
Christian or of any religion to believe
that really it's beautiful to try to
enter into other people's into an
intimate relationship with other people
to to understand their pains and their
joys
and that's what he's challenging us to
do so I don't really care whether you're
secular or a Christian or a Muslim or
Jew or a Hindu and I don't think he does
because he really wants you to develop a
better relationship with God through
whatever ways you can and that's what
he's so challenging about I think he is
you know when he talks about things that
upset him i think he talked he talks
about arrogance he talks about a lack of
humility he those are I think the big
sins that he talks about he talks about
building these walls of seclusion he's a
Jesuit which means he's a member of an
order that was started in the 15th
century when the church was really
looking interior was filled with monks
and other religious orders that were
inside closed walls and same asia's
wanted the church or at least the
Jesuits to be out in the community to be
on the frontier to be listening to poor
people to be working with them to be
inclusive in that regard and I think
Pope Francis really is focused on that
as well to going to the frontiers to not
be arrogant and to not be self folk
focused and to put that aside so these
sins of arrogance sins of contentment I
mean that's pretty crazy idea right it's
the sin of being content and he's
talking about put your contentment aside
put your comfort aside and live life
fully and that's a real challenge
because i like my routine i like my
comforts and he's saying put that aside
go out to the frontier the frontier
doesn't have to be halfway around the
world they can be in your neighborhood
you can go talk to the neighbor down the
street that you don't really like or you
don't know and you don't want to take
the time to get to know so that you know
that challenge to go to the frontiers is
a pretty pretty challenging one I think
the Pope gets troubled by anybody that
is arrogant that is not trying to reach
out to the poor and the powerless to
listen to them not trying to reach out
to your own neighbor and I think he's
always stood up against powerful
interests whether it was in Argentina or
his time as Pope saying that what we
need
is a more merciful society what we need
is to show more forgiveness and more
love and humility and I think that that
that message if you're fighting it back
against that that you don't have to be
you know empower in America or power in
argentina you know if you're in power
and you're pulling that power internally
and you're not reaching out to others
and you're not including the poor and
powerless in your policies you're going
to hear about it from the Pope that's a
great thing of Adam you know he
challenged you whether you're a Democrat
or a Republican in this country who
challenged you and he did in Argentina's
Cardinal whether you're a part of the
parent is government which was running
the government at that point in time or
whether you're a challenger to the
political power he's he's pushing us all
from a place of joy to reach out to the
frontier to include the poor and
powerless and if you're not doing that
you're going to hear from him but that's
what great prophets do right they
challenge you oftentimes they end up you
know getting killed because they
challenge you and your comfort they
challenge the powerful and the rich and
that's what makes him I think a great
prophet and a great leader
[Music]